do you really have to sacrifice
performance fan noise and battery life
by going with the 14-in 16 core M3 Max
MacBook Pro instead of the 16-in model
with exactly the same specs well I'm
going to answer that in this video by
doing a ton of performance Benchmark and
thermal throttle testing as well as
batter life because both of these
machines are at 100% battery life in
high power mode so let me unplug the
these Chargers and by the end of my
filming I'm going to show you guys the
differences in battery life and before I
get into all the real world performance
testing one thing we have to do is flip
these over and do a tear down to look at
the thermal system differences but I do
want to test one other thing first and
that is of course the speakers I'm doing
a different song because you guys keep
complaining about our other ones so
let's see if there's any differences in
speaker
[Music]
quality
and yep just as I thought there is more
base on the 16in and that's probably
because the speaker enclosures on the
inside are probably a little bit bigger
so let's actually find out by tearing
these down by the way guys I just
flipped these over and one thing you can
instantly tell is the difference in
thickness the 16in is quite a bit
thicker so you can probably expect to
have a bigger thermal system and as I'm
taking off these screws I wonder if you
guys can see the fingerprints on this
space black which by the way absolutely
beautiful and Moment of Truth we got the
16in and we got the 14 in and holy
smokes guys wow are you guys seeing how
big the fans are on the 16 in look at
the size of this fan compared to the 14
and not only that look at these Heat THS
right here where the fan ends compared
to the size of that look how much longer
that is not only that it's even bigger
the heat pipes themselves are thicker
all the way around but as far as the
actual heat sink for the M3 Max chip
they look exactly the same no
differences here and right here you can
see the difference in speakers and then
of course we have the battery size 72.6
W hours on the 14in compared to 99.6 so
this should give it a lot of extra
battery life we're going to find out at
the end of this video and now let's get
into performance the first thing I want
to do is do a quick SSD speed test just
in case there might be any differences
at all and so far it looks to be
basically neck and neck and just for
good measure we have geekbench 6 right
here 48 gigs of RAM on each they both
clock up to 4.05 with high power mode
and just as expected we have no
difference in the single core or the
multi-core performance and same for the
40 core GPU exactly the same with within
a margin of error and also the 3D Mark
Wildlife extreme unlimited test 188 FPS
no differenes there because we're not
thermal throttling or anything and now
let's jump into something that will have
some thermal throttling this is C bench
2024 this is going to be the 10minute
stress test but first I've got to show
you the coolest power bank I've ever
seen the Shar geek 100 from our sponsor
charge with its awesome transparent
design and a huge 25,600 milliamp hours
of battery which is Airline safe it puts
out 100 wats of power which is enough to
fast charge three devices at once with
Multi-Device compatibility like charging
your iPhone 15 Pro and M3 MacBook at the
same time it's also got a smart IPS
display which shows you the wattage info
in the remaining battery life while
coming with a 75 wat adjustable DC input
and output or a 100 W USBC input for a
full recharge in just 90 minutes it's
currently 31% off for their Black Friday
sale until November 27th so order today
using the link in the description below
all right guys already we're hitting
102° C on the 14 in and looks like the
16 is right behind it right off the bat
guys this is crazy because we're at the
same 102° C Peak on both of them but the
fans are running a lot faster around
4,000 RPM average and wow look at that
guys the package power is so much higher
on the 16in 52 watts compared to
36 this 14 in is seemingly throttling
already
3.13 pee clock speed compared to
3.58 which is probably its Max wow just
look at this it's relatively flat the
14in is throttling look how it's going
down towards 3 GHz and the really
surprising thing to me is that usually
apple has a limmit of 108° C but this is
stuck at 102 and it's not allowing more
power almost like it's forcing this 14
in to be limited down to 102° C not up
to 108 like we expected and it's
seriously throttling the performance all
right it's been over 5 minutes in the
stress test and I want to show you guys
the temps right here we have the 14in
right where the chip is at we have 43° C
and then from the fans we have a about
44° C output so it's pretty efficiently
getting rid of heat but why is it
throttling well let's look at the 16in
whoo
34° c 35° c on the
chip and
38° right there in the hinge holy moly
the 16 in is keeping it so
cool wow about what is that
8° higher on the 14-in chip and wait a
minute guys guys I did not expect this
the fans on the 16in actually slowed
down to about half the speed so I am now
hearing the 14-in like crazy it is still
at 100% fan speed maxing out and it's
loud and noisy there you go the test is
finished the fans are still running on
this thing to cool it down and we can
confirm that yes the 14in does sacrifice
performance we have
1,510 points on the 14in and
1,67 on the 16in that's
6.4% faster on the 16-in with the same
exact specs nothing is different except
for the size and once again I do want to
remind you that the fans slowed down and
got quieter on the 16in they were full
blast very noisy on the 14 the entire
time all right now with that said I
actually want to test the GPU Benchmark
within C bench 2024 because it has been
quite nice to test and I believe it does
support Ray tracing right off the bat
I'm seeing that both machines basically
Peak at around 30 Watts for GPU
differences so no thermal throttling on
the 14in in terms of the actual wattage
and wow look at that guys the 14in is
now maxing out its fans very very noisy
almost at idle on the 16in this is very
important to understand because if
you're planning to play AAA games or
high-end games and you're going to get
the 14in you're going to hear those fans
all the time this thing silent Gamers
you got to get the 16in with the full M3
Max wait a minute guys I think the 14in
is throttling on the chassis if you look
close at this chart you can see how high
the wattage spiked in red for the GPU in
the beginning but look right here it is
now throttling the 14in is throttling
the power look how low it is compared to
the beginning spikes on the 16in
completely flat the red spikes are
completely flat all the way through no
throttling at all once again it's been
about 5 minutes in this test let's whip
out the thermal can dang look at that
heat spot 45° C holy smokes that is hot
on the 14 in that's probably what's
throttling it because the temp itself is
83° C 86 de C so it's not the chip the
chassis is throttling 45° C over on the
16in we have 44° C wow it's actually
heat soaking as well but just slightly
less and wow impressive surprisingly
they're basically the same score
probably within margin of error around
13,000 points so even though we saw the
wattage kick down basically no impact on
performance not bad the fans on this
thing are still ramping down let's get
into some real world testing starting
with xcode programming to see if there's
any difference at all and wow we
actually have a difference I didn't
expect this 72.5 seconds on the 16in
82.5 seconds on the 14in 10 seconds
slower and the fans were still kicked up
trying to keep it cool which is just so
weird I did not expect a 10-second
difference in xcode and now let's finish
off with perhaps the hardest thing of
all this is going to be video editing in
Final Cut Pro playing Canon
R5 footage and this is 8k at 24 FPS so
I'm going to play both of these back and
look at the performance right away we
can see the temps kick up we can see
that it's using about 85 to 87% of the
GPU and about
67% of the CPU and surprisingly guys the
14in is stuttering more than the 16in
can you see that look at that we're
getting up to 62 watts of package Power
60 WT compared to 40 Watts that's 50%
more wattage going to the 16in likely
because this 14 is throttling and
looking at the performance Core Power
3.5 GHz clock speed under three on the
14in same thing for the GPU wattage 22
on the 16in only 14 15 13 on the 14in
the GPU is throttling and once again
just looking at these side by side the
16-in playback is by a long shot
smoother than the 14in so much
stuttering this is an excellent playback
test going to the extreme where we're
not using encoders using CPU and GPU the
16in is just killing it and for our
final test we're actually going to
export this and see which one finishes
first and wow guys we have our scores
the 16in M3 Max took 4 minutes and 44
seconds while the 14in took 6 minutes
and 36 seconds that's a minute and 52
seconds longer and these are the same
exact specs for these chips wow that is
a massive difference and yes it confirms
a lot of thermal throttling on the 14in
so there you go that was all of our
thermal testing and the last thing to do
is check up on the battery life 14-in
first we have
22% 14-in M3 Max and on the 16
42% that is a lot of extra battery life
and keep in mind guys that this 16-in
display is larger which has more screen
real estate and takes up more power not
only that but it's a 3.5 5K resolution
display compared to 3K so it's pushing
more pixels across a bigger size at 600
nits on both of these and still we have
a lot more battery life on the 16in so
with all of that tested which one should
you buy well I can only think of one
good reason to buy the 14in over the 16
and that is if you absolutely must have
the extra portability and you don't care
about what you have to sacrifice to get
it portability is all you don't care
about the extra fan noise the worst
battery life the worst performance in
some of these cases that's the only
reason why you should buy the 14in but
for the 16 we had lower fan noise
overall less of the time we had the fans
running it was quieter more silent it
ran cooler you get much better battery
life you get the bigger screen real
estate which is better for watching
movies and multitasking you get the
better speakers and you get better
performance I've got to say guys just
buy the 16-in MacBook Pro if you don't
care about the portability I would
recommend it especially if you're a
gamer that's going to be playing games
you're not going to be having to deal
with that fan noise because this thing
can keep it cool with the better thermal
system so with that said hopefully you
guys enjoy this video and if you did
check out one of those videos right
there subscribe above for more tests
like this thanks for watching and we'll
see you in the next
one
[Music]